j'ai perdu ma famille il ya trois ans ce
n'était pas un accident
il y avait une bombe dans cet avion
j'ai besoin de votre aide pour trouver
ceux qui ont fait ça j'ai rien à perdre
et votre vie elle jamais rien à [ __ ]
je vais vous dire une seule fois si vous
réussissez ça en vaudrait pas le coup
[Musique]
c'est lui qui a fabriqué la bombe et en
liberté
tu me promets que tu feras rien de
stupide pourquoi êtes vous ici pour vous
offrir une vengeance du comment
feriez-vous saint jean
violemment
vous êtes beaucoup plus humaine que je
ne l'aurais cru alors c'est un bon
déguisement
n'avez pas idée de l'ampleur de la
catastrophe que vous avez causés
[Musique]
c'est la juste les larcins